[Música]
atenção crianças para os três desafios
estúpidos que podem demandar direto para
o beleléu cavar um buraco até a shin
cedentes de uma cobra banho de banheira
com tubarão
esses desafios não só piadas mas a
internet está cheia de brincadeiras
realmente perigosas
[Música]
são brincadeiras com buzina camisinha
silver teve coisas que entre amigos a
gente nem sempre percebe risco mas tem
que ficar bem ligado para não confundir
brincadeira com cilada é porque uma
brincadeira que não afetou um amigo pode
ser fatal com você mostra que quem pensa
o desafio de verdade é que fica de fora
explica os riscos para eles nunca
compartilhou os desafios e tenha coragem
de dizer não coloca sua vida em primeiro
lugar
[Música]
muitos jovens e crianças foram vítimas
dessas brincadeiras por não saberem
agora você já sabe que o seu compromisso
é compartilhar este vídeo em suas redes
sociais
[Música]
[Aplausos]
boa tarde eu vou me apresentar
inicialmente submetem interessados
sou engenheiro civil de formação
trabalho na área imobiliária
sou casado tem três filhos o mais novo
deles demitem perdeu a vida em 2014
aos 16 anos vítima do jogo do desmaio
como nós vimos aí novo vídeo
esses jogos esses desafios que estão
soltos por aí são não tem nada de jogo
esse é um linguajar que é usado não só
no brasil mas em outros países nos
estados unidos na frança são
classificados o chamado de jogos mas não
tem nada de jogo nem tem nada de
interessante feliz medição de risco
muito grande que os jovens correm são
praticados por jovens de 6 a 17 anos
independente de gênero independente de
raça independente de condição econômica
e praticam pelas mais diversas
motivações seja a busca de uma sensação
de euforia busca de uma sensação de
relaxamento a busca ou pertencer a um
determinado grupo o descobriu o limite
do corpo ou simplesmente fazer um
desafio e quem pratica essas
brincadeiras não tem a consciência do
real isso do perigo que corre e
infelizmente muitos casos terminam em
morte ou em sequelas irreversíveis nas
brincadeiras a maioria delas elas
consistem em cortar o fluxo de oxigênio
e esse corte de de oxigênio e que os
jogos imagem não controlar e não
controlo terminam aí como nós falamos em
acidentes
essas brincadeiras elas não são novas
na verdade acontece há muito tempo o que
mudou foi a forma de divulgação com o
avanço das conexões com o avanço da
internet vem evoluindo de uma forma
muito rápida o a informação e o conteúdo
que se consume então em 2010 existiam
500 vídeos com esse tema jogo do desmaio
agora o último número que nós temos já
existem 18 mil só em português
a nível de brasil então realmente é uma
prática bastante arriscada e que tá aí
soltando mundo quando se passa por uma
situação de revés
um acidente como se nós passamos é muito
importante para que a aceitação venha
que se tem a compreensão e assim três
meses depois do acidente com o filho
estávamos eu e minha mulher em uma
platéia assim como o grande auditório
participando do 2º colóquio
internacional de brincadeiras perigosas
na frança estavam reunidos
representantes de oito países
autoridades da área de saúde e
autoridades da área de educação pais e o
assunto foi exaustivamente discutido por
dois dias e à conclusão que nós chegamos
ainda bastante fragilizadas claro
naquele momento foi que existe um mundo
que nós não conhecíamos
isso foi em outubro de 2014
em abril de 2015 estávamos lá novamente
eu e minha mulher dessa vez pra morar
mais de dois meses na frança e
participar ativamente junto a pé as aps
associação dos pais os filhos vítimas
dos jogos desmaio e participamos
ativamente do trabalho deles nós
freqüentamos salas de aula para assistir
prevenção nós estivemos em hospitais nós
estivemos em reunião de pais em reunião
de conselho
vendo qual era metodologia como era
desenvolvido este trabalho já que eles
vinham obtendo resultados satisfatórios
a nível de conscientização ea nível de
consciência então essa experiência lá
a partir desse momento a criação de uma
entidade deixou de ser vontade nossa
passou a ser consciência
aí nós acumulamos muito conhecimento de
um mundo que nós desconhecíamos e tava
claro pra nós a vulnerabilidade que a
nossa juventude estava e nasceu assim
que o instituto de me cuidar
o time admite meu filho cuidar daquilo
que está na essência do próprio
instituto
nós trabalhamos sempre com cuidado de
alertar e não no cuidado de alarmar que
alarmaram constrói
então nós buscamos ter 11 investigação
trabalho muito cuidadoso com as
informações que nós passamos para frente
nós trabalhamos pesquisas
sistematicamente estudos e pesquisa
análise de material para que a gente
tenha consciência daquilo que a gente
está divulgando nós fazemos prevenções
nós desenvolvemos módulos de prevenção
separados cada modo falando linguajar
apropriado então nós temos prevenção
para crianças
temos prevenção para jovens prevenções
para os pais prevenção para os
educadores
o ideal quando nós fomos demandados é
que inicie pelos educadores nice nas
escolas
na seqüência os pais participam pra
tomar conhecimento e aí uma decisão de
paz com educadores se vai fazer o
trabalho para os jovens
então nós temos essa atuação principal
do instituto de me cuidar e levar a
prevenção à frente a gente trabalha com
o lema de conhecer compreender prevenir
temos também uma ação jurídica porque
nós precisamos monitorar e retirar o
conteúdo indevido de internet então
essas ações às vezes são necessárias
quando a demanda amigável não funciona
mas já tivemos que tirar um livro
digital que com esse conteúdo totalmente
impróprio nós tivemos que tirar de dois
sites aí de venda de livros digitais mas
precisou de uma demanda jurídico e
também para fazer o acompanhamento da
regularização da legislação que visa
justamente têm um controle sobre esse
conteúdo indevido ea retirada a tempo a
nós temos como três grandes metas dentro
do instituto
a primeira delas é que a gente tenha um
filtro para evitar que o conteúdo
indevido sequer chegue se a esteja lá no
ar e em um alarme caso passa alguma
coisa isso teria que ser trabalhado que
é possível tecnicamente é possível
depende de
vontade política de vencer alguns
interesses comuns ainda mas é possível
sim e assim estaríamos protegido de um
material indevido chegar sem nenhum
controle para as crianças
então esse é o primeiro é o filtro o
alarme o outro faz se necessária a
criação de um núcleo de prevenção em
cada estado do brasil
o nosso país é muito muito grande e
embora as realidades sejam muito
diferentes
essa realidade dessa prática ela ocorre
os interiores ocorre na capital em todas
as classes como eu já falei e faz
necessário isso nós estamos de mandados
já dirigiu por três estados para fazer
esses núcleos acontecer ainda este ano
mas teve de sonho do título de me cuidar
é ter um núcleo de prevenção trabalhando
enterro interligado e trocando
informações e cada estado do brasil e o
outro que a gente precisa para que seja
compreendido é a criação a implantação
da autópsia psicológica isso é uma
ferramenta que já existe em outros
países ou alguma ferramenta semelhante
que faça com que em caso de acidente que
leve à morte essa morte seja
classificada corretamente não seja
classificada como suicídio ou morte
acidental quem pratica o jogo desmaio
não busca sequer desmaiar
muito menos tirar a própria vida então
essa autópsia psicológica é muito
importante para que se tenha estatística
porque sem estatística não vai se
trabalhar as prevenções em uma única
pesquisa que nós temos conhecimento que
aconteceu no brasil para crianças de 9 a
17 anos que já não são tão crianças
crianças e adolescentes jovens 40% já
havia praticado o jogo da nova geração
pelo menos uma vez
então isso realmente é um dado bastante
preocupante é algumas realizações do
instituto e merecem ser trazidas para
conhecimento 14 meses depois da
participação do acontecido com o dimitri
nós realizamos aqui em fortaleza o
primeiro colóquio internacional no
brasil de brincadeiras perigosas
trouxemos as pessoas da frança nesse
nesse momento para o cérebro da pessoa
do representante da entidade da áfrica
do sul
e convocamos a sociedade e pais
educadores psicólogos médicos para
debater para conhecer o assunto
infelizmente não é um assunto agradável
a apresentar mas precisava ser
apresentado e e se coloca nós tivemos
uma resposta muito positiva a nível de
conscientização do que estava
acontecendo no mundo e até então no
brasil nós não sabíamos
no ano seguinte em 2016 nós realizamos o
2º colóquio internacional
seria como o fechamento desta vez vieram
os participantes dos estados unidos
inclusive um detetive e chegou a mudar
um laudo ele deu esse depoimento aqui
chegou a mudar um laudo classificado
erradamente depois que tomou
conhecimento da existência das
brincadeiras perigosas e logo depois
deste 2º colóquio infelizmente aconteceu
um acidente no interior de são paulo com
o jovem estava jogando online tal um dia
alguém desafio alguém pra ter prática o
jogo de maio depois aí felizmente o
garoto acidentou-se morreu nesse momento
nós do instituto fomos bastante
demandados em busca de conhecimento
porque cada vez que acontece um acidente
desse é meio que a sociedade entre em
pânico sem saber o que fazer sem saber
como agir
então nós mantemos esse relacionamento
com essas entidades internacionais
especificamente especificamente escuta o
guest na áfrica do sul a pé as na frança
eo ex caos nos estados unidos porque
além de uma troca de informação nós
trocamos experiências e acontecimentos
depois nós iniciamos o trabalho
instituto já surgiram vários tipos de
desafios diferentes e que igualmente
perigosa que nós não tínhamos
conhecimento então nós trabalhamos meio
de uma forma globalizada para acelerar
as ações que são necessárias
outra coisa que nós fizemos foi esse
livro que está aí tem perigo não é um
livro uma abordagem lúdica para crianças
de 5 a 11 anos é um livro educativo
ilustrado mostrando o cuidado que a
criança precisa ter com o seu corpo como
proteger bem o seu corpo não deixar
ninguém tocar o risco de cortar o fluxo
de oxigênio seria uma primeira tentativa
mais geral de uma prevenção feita
assim para todo o público tivemos
participando de audiência pública na
assembléia legislativa para que seja
instituído aqui no ceará
anualmente a semana de prevenção de
brincadeiras para os jovens que vêm
participando de audiência pública na
câmara dos deputados em brasília para
que seja regulamentado essa a exibição e
retirada quando necessário do conteúdo
indevido na internet etc estamos
trabalhando ações pontuais todas
caminhando na direção daqueles três
objetivos maiores que nós buscamos
alcançar quando nós pensamos em
formalizar o instituto que me cuida nós
nos demos uma missão para o instituto ea
missão do instituto é manter acesa a
chama do legado de um jovem
atuando em seus sonhos e suas práticas
valorizando a vida
então nós trabalhamos além da causa do
desmaio dos jogos de desmaio de emitir
um olhar muito especial para os animais
de rua ele saia na rua vinham os animais
correndo atrás dele porque tem uma
imagem dele se na rua e uma facilidade
muito grande não só de falar com os
animais na rua mais e trazer para casa
também não chegava com o cachorro
chegava com gato e nós não gostaríamos
de interromper essa prática então 12
meses atrás eu cheguei em casa com uma
gata que peguei na rua então a gente
continua não só com essa atuação pessoal
mas apoiando e diversas ongs trabalhando
castrações trabalhando é tratamentos que
precisam ser feito resgates lar
temporário e mantendo assim a chama da
prática dele acesa e o sonho ele gostava
muito de natureza
gostava muito de turismo de natureza e
então nós iniciamos uma ação com os
guias de turismo no cariri na chapada do
araripe instalar o geopark araripe
trabalhando para formar e inserir no
mercado de trabalho dias de turismo de
natureza então nós temos parceria dela
com geopark araripe temos um trabalho
todo acontecendo lá neste momento
bem gente
eu não estou sozinho nesse projeto
quando estava lá fora agora no coffee
break
alguém pegou a minha mão e disse sempre
de mãos dadas
eu tenho meu lado a minha mulher com
toda a sua força a sua serenidade avisa
que trabalha no instituto de me cuidar
comigo e dando força seja no silêncio
seja um sorriso vocês no olhar e nós
juntos focamos esse projeto em meus
filhos que tem também apoio e é muito
importante o apoio que eu recebo e que
nós recebemos dos amigos das pessoas que
compartilham aquilo que nós publicamos
em mídia social das pessoas que abrem
espaço para a gente levar o nosso
trabalho de prevenção que nos chamam pra
falar um pouco do instituto de me cuidar
tem uma causa e precisa ser cuidado têm
vidas belíssimas de jovens crianças
sendo posto em risco aí então é muito
importante esse apoio espaço que as
escolas abrem abre para nós cada vez que
a gente é chamado a gente tem um
sentimento de gratuito diz muito grande
e assim nós alimentamos sua saudade para
não viver uma saudade vazia
nós vivemos a saudade é alimentado por
um trabalho que a gente entende fazer
bem ao próximo e isso de alguma forma
permite que a gente não perca a
capacidade de amar e que a gente não
perca a capacidade de sorrir muito
obrigado
[Aplausos]